all right joining us now on the Dan
Patrick show Dan cats big cat from
pardon my take part podcast on barstool
sports they can't let me get right to
the main issue yesterday we've discussed
this you and I what's your policy on
Super Bowl Sunday are you Lou lean
towards hunkering down with a TV yeah
keep an eye on your bets or do you go
cuz I'm sure you get invited to party as
you live in the Big Apple what's your
policy so it used to be
it's different now because we obviously
have to work on Sunday night so we
watched the Super Bowl in the office PFT
and I and our producers but back in the
day I would get invited Super Bowl
parties I've been to a couple I think
ultimately the Super Bowl is a great
event to watch with a small group of
people talking like 6 or less people
that you know are into the game people
you know that are into the best and have
that type of group because once you get
over 10 you're gonna have people who
don't care you're gonna have people who
ask you about your best you're gonna
probably show the worst version of
yourself when you start to lose all that
money like you do every year now big hey
you know and that I fall in love with
quarterbacks you've had a little bit of
the same problem so Blake bortles had a
tough year one of your guys then Jared
golf's your other guy how do you think
he played last night I mean he was he
was terrible we all can agree on that I
you know I am friends with Jared and I
think he'd tell you himself
it was a really really bad performance
itself like the moment was a little too
big for he and McVeigh at at times but I
think more than anything you have to
give credit to the Patriots defense what
they did to confuse them what they did I
mean I read a staff and the Patriots
played more man than any other team all
year and then they played zone basically
all night so it's that ability to change
by the Patriots that won them the Super
Bowl and they're able to always adapt to
situations and it was bad for Jared I
don't think anyone is sitting here
saying that it was like any other
anything else but he's young and they
will should be back in this spot at
least a couple more times so hopefully
he can learn from it and get better now
you're a football guy do you like three
three games in the fourth quarter or is
that not on your palate
I like I do like you know games where
there's a lot of pumps games
a lot of Defense I think with the Super
Bowl it's so weird because it's it's
changed over time we're in you know
growing up to the 90s you saw a bunch of
Super Bowls where the game was not that
good because the Cowboys would kill
someone or the eldest the 49ers killed
the Chargers but I think last 10 years
or so we've been spoiled with very good
very compelling Super Bowl games so last
night it definitely felt weird to watch
that I would be fine with a 13-3 game
and maybe November if it's a Super Bowl
and it's our last football for 6 months
7 months I would prefer her a little
more excitement a little more often but
now that we've gotten the game out of
the way and all the X's and O's and
whatnot we could get to the things that
matter like prop bets do you have a prop
bet that stood out and maybe one that
you cleaned up on or the most compelling
prop bet for you was what well I had
tails I gave everyone tails that was the
easiest prop out of all the tails now in
it yeah I did
I did and then I know Paulie had the
same as me but I basically hammered
every single Julian Edelman prop before
the game I had him over over receptions
over yards over yards for his first
catch those all hit and then I did get I
did have a little inside tip even though
I think Ravel was getting roasted right
now on Twitter but I got an inside tip
about the maroon 5 songs so I was able
to win a little bit on that oh you you
had an insider maybe during rehearsal is
that where your inkling I didn't have
someone who told me that they were told
so it was a secondhand tip that when you
get a secondhand tip like that it's hard
to then go tell everyone else I told a
few people what I had heard and I was
able to get the thing is you don't get
to win a lot of money on those puffs
because they just they limit it because
there's a human element to it and people
can get inside tips and can find out you
know what their first song is going to
be or what what what we know how long
the national anthem is going to be but
it is always fun to get those inside
tips every now and then now big cat you
always go with the over and what point
last night did you give up that it was
gonna even come close or do you still
stand by that bet yeah
okay so here's the spin zone and um I'll
just say to Pat myself on the back it's
genius
but here we go that was the lowest
scoring Super Bowl of all time all-time
all-time I think the second lowest was
21 total points say it was Super Bowl
five or six if you are going to lose a
bet if you lose the bet losing it in
historical fashion right it's actually
worth something
I lost the over-under last night by 40
and a half that is almost impossible to
do so you have your possible to do for
football games this is a great story I
have a story yeah correct like I will be
telling my kids and my grandkids someday
hey you know I bet an over/under in the
Super Bowl and lost by 40 and a half
points and it makes that is that is
actually almost impossible to do to lose
that drastically and by that large of a
margin then I'm actually okay with it I
would rather lose this way then have it
be you know the game finished
32:28 error sorry that would have hated
put 32:24 and moves by two points so I'm
okay with it I'm part of history I can
say it's like a where were you when you
know the Miracle on Ice where were you
in all these important moments well
where were you when the over/under the
Super Bowl right by 40 and a half point
all right damn cats big cat from Barstow
sports part of my take podcast joining
us in the Dan Patrick show now I'm
checking my records you seem to be the
only barstool employee was not arrested
or accosted in any way during super week
does that make you the smart guy or the
soft guy that can this actually hurt
your rep well so I would have probably
been part of the crew that got arrested
on Monday night but the famous last
words
my boss Dave told me he didn't want me
to go to media night because I would
cause a stir so and then he went and
caused the biggest stir so I think I'm
fine you know it's crazy because the NFL
did it last night again where they
kicked him out and he just told the
story on one of our shows but they
basically put him in a holding cell
under the stadium and then with like
three minutes left in the game just let
him out because what keeps happening is
the NFL
Taine's him and then the regular police
say this is the dumbest thing I've ever
seen why are we wasting resources on it
and let them go
so it's almost like the NFL couldn't be
playing into our hands more by giving us
stories but never actually getting him
in any legal trouble like he's not even
in he's not even half he's enough to go
back to Atlanta to appear in court or
anything
he was just held in a Cell the
underneath the stadium for I don't know
an hour and then just kick right back on
the street
all right big Ken I'll give you a choice
of three teams who is gonna be back in
the Super Bowl next my Philadelphia
Eagles your Chicago Bears or the LA Rams
oh I would say the Bears won yeah I said
the Bears won Rams - I don't I'm not a
person once guy why so evil straight I
okay so the Rams are interesting because
they did go all in this year I don't
know what they're gonna do next year
right like I said pretty sure they have
to pay a few people sue obviously was on
a one-year contract I the Bears have a
better overall team younger team and
it's continued no it's constructed for
the window to open right now
the Eagles what I guess I guess the
Eagles maybe want one too tied for
second will be the Eagles in the ramps
there's number one I think the pears are
gonna be in the Super Bowl in the next
three you just gonna ignore the kicker
issue you're not even gonna talk about
it we were onto a new kicker like it's
already been solved big cat week he's
not a bear anymore we ran into Robbie
gold at meteor row and he still lives in
the Chicagoland area I don't know if you
could go fund me or what you could do
but we got to get this guy back I know
we do and you know the crazy thing with
the Robbie Buhl thing you remember Pauly
like he actually wasn't great his last
year with the Bears right kind of all
fell apart but I yeah I mean I would
take him in a heartbeat over what what
we had but yeah the kicker situation has
been solved Cody Parker's no longer
Chicago Bear he might be technically but
he's gonna get caught and we're gonna be
fine all right last thing part of my
take podcast where are you guys placing
your loyalties for the draft with
quarterbacks coming up Josh Allen was
your guy last year have you guys
collectively decided who are you gonna
ride to the promised land I think we
have to
with will Greer because of the Dana
Holgorsen connection and we now we're
obviously Houston Houston what is
Houston the Cougars Cougars very much
acoustic Cougars Iceland
so that was Houston cougar fans but we
were West Virginia fans when Dana
Holgorsen was still coaching there so I
think we're gonna go with will Grier but
it's gonna be this is my favorite time
of year I know it is for you McLovin
the time of the year where we get
Superbowl up until the draft where
basically there's three or four
quarterbacks that ever will talk
themselves into even though they
probably shouldn't be drafted in the top
ten of the draft absolutely everyone
talking about Todd Gurley zni what about
big cats back when are you coming back
to hoop to though our Saturday morning
run I'm gonna try this week i'ma try
this week come back awesome buddy we'll
see you soon thanks for your time for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]